hello hello
[Applause]
Robin
[Music]
you know my dad
[Applause]
by the way
your docks are good if there's any
angels in heaven they're all nurses male
and female
you know why you guys let us you guys
make us allow us to live
nurses make you one of it
I'm not joking you'll lie there in the
ICU which I've done for a long time and
you look at those machines and you know
the line goes flat that it's over but
you just get tired
you don't care
when I was at wall to read all that time
after a couple craniotomies I was lying
there and I had a nurse named Pearl
Nelson military
she'd come in and do things and I don't
think you'll learn the medical school
Nursery School
she'd whisper in my ear I didn't
couldn't understand her she wished when
she leaned down
he'd actually breathed on me to make
sure that I was there was a connection
to the human connection
she even went home and brought back her
pillow from her own bed because he
didn't knew the one where I had the one
comfortable
but I'm not joking
my son Beau came back from Iraq after
being
all that time within shouting distance
of a burn pit he had stage four
glioblastoma we went as an incredibly
healthy guy came back
and for 18 months he fought
the nurses
the docks were incredible
that the nurses would say toward the end
he'd come in to look at him I said no no
not not now Doc the doctors knew enough
to know that it wasn't the time the
nurse didn't think it was there
you're so underestimated you really are
and there's no ways to diminish doctors
but I want to tell you something nurses
single most underestrated profession in
the world thank you
[Applause]
and Robin talking about her journey
my dad if you have a seat please take it
if you don't come on up on stage with me
you know and Robin thanks for the
introduction Robin my dad used to say a
little differently
my dad used to say everybody needs a
little bit of breathing room
just a little bit of breathing room
at the end of the month
can you in fact pay your bills and still
be certain your family's gonna be okay
we lived in a uh three we weren't poor
we were typical middle class family
four kids we lived in a three bedroom
split level home with a Grandpop
and my headboard was up against the wall
where my dad's on the other side my dad
and mom
one night I remember my dad you could
hear how Restless he was
I got up the next morning I was in high
school my senior year
I said what's the matter mom what's on
my dad
he said this company just dropped health
insurance
well you know a lot of people face that
a lot of people worry about it right now
but he said just a little breathing room
a little bit of certainty
just a little bit of certainty it
matters
so Robin thank you for your introduction
and mayor Bobby Dyer mayor came out I
told the mayor he was very gracious with
me even though I'm one of those
Democrats
Bobby where are you there you are he
came out to the airport to greet me and
I said you know what the worst sentence
in the English language is
I'm at the airport
thank you again for your graciousness Mr
Mayor I appreciate it very much
and to all the mayors
all the Mayors stand up come on all the
Mayors stand up
[Applause]
[Music]
toughest job in American politics you
know why
you all know where they live
no way to go to the Dunkin Donuts or the
local store without Mr Mayor what about
this but anyway thank you for what you
do I really genuinely mean it and it's
great to be back in Virginia Beach
almost so many Brave women and men who
served armed forces and this make this
nation so strong I really mean
[Applause]
well they although they couldn't be here
today you have two amazing Senators you
know that Tim Kaine and Mark Warner
they are true champions of this great
state and representative Bobby Scott
a lifelong fighter Virginia workers and
families who's back in D.C introducing
we call the pro act to make sure unions
have an equal right to organize if they
want to organize
I want to thank all the health care
workers here today
I really mean it thank you thank you by
the way you care for people when they
need it most but the most important
thing is you know what you do when you
help someone in trouble or need
you you
provide them the dignity they're looking
for
the dignity just to be treated with
dignity
that's what all Americans deserve peace
of mind that comes from knowing that an
illness if it strikes or an accident
occurs you can get Quality Medical Care
and recover and heal
but we all know that too many folks
don't have that peace of mind too many
folks lie in bed at night staring at the
ceiling wondering what will happen if
their spouse gets cancer the child gets
sick or something happens to them
well they have to will have the money to
pay the medical bills who have to sell
the house I get it
that's why since I was sworn in as
president two years ago my
administration's Focus intensely on
getting more people affordable health
care and bringing down medical costs so
you have a little bit of breathing room
again just breathing
and that's exactly what happens when we
protect and strengthen programs like
Medicare and Medicaid which millions of
Americans rely on Millions
and spend my focus and I believe we've
made significant progress now we need to
finish the job
[Applause]
and that's what I'd like to talk about a
little bit about today
my plan that's in stark contrast to not
by the way there's an awful lot of
really good Republicans but the mighty
Republicans are a different breed of cat
no they're not bad or good they're just
very they're very different it's kind of
like in my view sort of two Republican
parties
and I've served a long time some of my
closest as that joke goes but not a joke
my closest friends and government have
been my Republican colleagues in the
Senate
and folks in Congress they want to
eliminate a lot of Health Care coverage
those Mega Republicans increased costs
for millions of Americans and make deep
cuts and programs that families and
seniors depend on and that's what the
stake now
two years ago when I was sworn in the
economy was reeling and the pandemic was
raging
we lost over a million people hard to
believe over a million people
and our Health Care system was at the
breaking point
and all all the health characters here
remember better than anyone those dark
dark months
as a number of kova deaths kept Rising
hospitals had to have have patients in
hallways literally setting up tents in
their parking lots in a situation where
every because everything was full every
bed was full
that's what we're up against when I took
office we immediately got to work
we turned it around
I signed into law The Landmark American
Rescue plan which provided the resources
to get covid-19 under control our
economy back on its track
and many of you worked around the clock
to get people vaccinated against kova
19. we went from 3.5 million people
vaccinated when I took office to 230
million fully vaccinated today
[Applause]
we made vaccinations available all
Americans with a plan based on the
quality
many of you went in the communities have
been ignored in the past
when you went into the public housing
areas you went to places where they
didn't usually go to make sure that
everyone everyone had equal access to
this life-saving
shots
and it worked we came through but was a
terrible cost as I said over a million
people died from the virus in addition
we expanded health insurance for
Millions under the Affordable Care Act
by making it easier to sign up and by
making it cheaper to get better health
care and Affordable Care saving families
eight hundred dollars a year
where I come from eight hundred dollars
matters
result is more than three million people
have newly signed up to the Affordable
Health Care Act today more Americans
have health insurance under the
Affordable Health Care Act than ever
before and folks didn't stop there
Americans pay more for prescription
drugs than any Nation on Earth let me
say that again
the United States of America we pay more
for prescription drugs than any any
Nation on Earth
and I've been fighting for years as a
senator done as a vice president
to get Medicare to be able to negotiate
lower drug prices for these companies
guess what the only outfit they couldn't
negotiate with you know but that's how
the VA works and it should work they
negotiate so we're only going to pay x
amount of dollars for that particular
treatment
and if you wanted any any help with from
the VA system you pay that you charge
that or no more
well finally we got it done
I signed a historic inflation reduction
Act
we took on powerful interests bring down
health care costs so you can sleep
better at night and it's it's had
profound impact for example one in 10
Americans one in 10 Americans has
diabetes
every day
Millions need instantly control their
diabetes to stay alive insulin has been
around for a hundred years
costs that make that drug and package it
is make it ten dollars in package and
thirteen
but you've been paying three four five
hundred dollars a month for that
but big Pharma has been unfairly charged
into that record profits
not anymore
[Applause]
we capped the cost of incident 35
dollars a month for seniors on Medicare
when I introduced it it was for all
Americans got over 200 000 kids
type 2 diabetes they're not covered but
guess what type 1 diabetes
has changed their lives but here's the
deal
my some of my friends cut out everything
but the Medicare piece
but guess what we've got it covered for
everybody we've got to finish the job
and by the way
look at the profit margins of these
companies they're hundreds of billions
of dollars
it's not it's not like they're getting
hurt come on
let's cap the cost and this is a 35 a
month for every single American who
needs it
the only country doesn't do that
this law also caps out-of-pocket drug
costs for seniors on Medicare at a
maximum of two thousand dollars a year
no matter what drug you have to take
totally
a lot of you know we're making real
progress in my cancer initiative Cancer
drugs though can cost up to 10 12 14 000
a year
but you're never going to have to pay
next year more than two thousand dollars
if you're all the drugs
[Applause]
plus if drug companies raise prices
faster than inflation Rises they'll have
to pay Medicare back the difference and
guess what it's not only fair it reduces
the deficit when you do that
folks we're really giving Medicare the
power to negotiate lower drug prices
just like the VA has done for years for
veterans bringing down prescription drug
costs doesn't just save money for
seniors and Medicare it's going to have
a significant effect on the federal
deficit it's going to lower the debt by
159 billion dollars
and you say well how can that be Joe
well right now the government our tax
dollars pay out through Medicare the
help for the prescription drugs
if they have to pay out 150 159
000 billion dollars LED
less for prescription drugs
then it reduces the deficit
so folks it's a win-win
it saves taxpayers money it makes
Medicare stronger reduces government
spending overall
for years we've been trying to make that
happen Democrats and Republicans for
years bigger farmer has been able to
block it but long last we got it done
this is historic progress
I wish I could save my friends on the
other side all my friends outside are
there to protect and defend and build on
like I am
again sadly the mega Republicans
the Congress of those in Congress have
threatened undo the gains they wanted to
do away with this Affordable Care Act
some threatened to fall on the national
debt unless I accept certain economic
plans
now let me explain the national debt you
all know we think we all know it it's
the accumulated debt over 200 years
every year has accumulated over 200
years
the federal government has never ever
once reneged on that debt we've never
questioned our credit
and guess what
let's remember the last Administration
increased the federal debt
by 25 percent the 200-year debt in four
years they increased it by 25 percent
200 years
folks how did Congress respond
well quite frankly the only responsible
thing
they paid the debt
they voted three times to keep paying
America's bills to pay the debt without
preconditions without a crisis
if they paid the American debt then why
in God's name are they threatening not
to pay it now
so folks
it's not all the other team I'm not
saying everybody in the team says that
but it's just politics
and they've got no business playing
politics for the lives of the American
people on a nation's economy
folks
and by the way you know you hear ads
about the big spend in Joe bidened
in two years
I reduced the debt
1.7 billion dollars
1.7 billion dollars the largest deficit
reduction in American history
I remember the new house speaker but not
a bad guy about how we should proceed to
settle our differences without
jeopardizing the full faith and credit
of the United States of America which
would be a disaster in terms of our
economy here's what he said
when I said to him actually
instead of making threats about default
which can be catastrophic even if it
doesn't happen because the the markets
around the world began to hedge against
it
and it affects economies let's take that
off the table
and let's let's have a conversation
about how we're going to grow the
economy lower the cost and reduce
deficit each of us I said let's lay out
our respective budgets on March the 9th
I'm going to lay down in detail
every single thing every tax that's out
there that I'm proposing and no one over
400 is making less than 400 000 is going
to pay a penny more than taxes but lay
it out by March 9th everything and what
we're going to cut what we're going to
spend what we're going to do just lay it
on the table
and I've invited them to Republicans
they should do the same thing lay their
proposal on the table and we can sit
down
and we can agree and disagree we can
fight it out
when I introduced my budget you'll see
that's going to invest in America lower
Health costs and protective strength of
Social Security Medicare while cutting
the deficit more than two trillion
dollars over the next 10 years
but by the way
I want to make it clear
I'm going to raise some taxes
many of your billionaires out there
you're going to stop paying a three
percent
not a joke
the idea that a billionaire we used to
have 600 or so in the United States of
America now there's a thousand
the idea that they pay at a rate
that is lower than the rate of a police
officer a school teacher a nurse is
bizarre
you're going to see the people making
less than four hundred thousand dollars
here as I said from the very beginning
will not pay an additional single penny
in any tax
[Applause]
[Music]
if I can hold a second one of the
reasons I was able to keep the debt down
this time around
they're the Fortune 500 companies
they're good companies by the way I come
from the corporate capital of the world
Delaware
more corporations are incorporating the
state of Delaware and every other state
in America combined
I got elected 36 years worth of that so
I'm not anti-corporation but I think
everybody should pay or take a fair shot
pay a fair share
now look here's the deal
reason why I was able to lower the
deficit and still expand programs like
Health Care
was there were 55 corporations in 2020
when I came to office
who made 40 billion dollars and didn't
pay a single penny in tax not one penny
well guess what I did a terrible thing
I got past overwhelmingly majest my
team's vote
I got passed 15 tax my God 15 percent
raise your hand if you'd accept a 15 tax
no I'm not joking
or raised enough money
to allow me to do the things I've been
able to do
15 minimum tax
like I said 40 billion in profit
I says 55 corporations we're paying zero
as for my my mega Republican friends
they say they want to reduce the deficit
we did the math
based on what we know so far they could
change their minds their plans would
explode the deficit increasing it more
than three trillion dollars over the
next 10 years
because they wanted they want to cut
taxes for the very wealthy again
they want to cut taxes for large
corporations
want to take back the power we just gave
Medicare and Medicaid to negotiate we
should raise prices
and they would have a huge giveaway to
Big Pharma and cost taxpayers billions
of dollars
and if they say they want to cut the
deficit
but their plans actually would explode
the deficit how are they going to make
the numbers add up what are they going
to cut that's the big question
for millions of Americans Health Care
hangs in the balance
will they continue to fight cut the
Affordable Care Act and make health
insurance more expensive for millions of
Americans
Republicans have been trying to undo the
Affordable Care Act
since it passed 13 years ago
they voted to change and repeal the act
as a fact on the record more than 50
times in four years that it existed
50 times
and they made repealing it part of
virtually every Republican budget since
the law was passed from the Trump
Administration budgets to Congressional
budgets to their budget plans for just
this past year
so let's be clear about the consequences
if you get rid of the Affordable Care
Act would mean that more than 100
million Americans
with pre-existing conditions
would lose the critical protections they
have now the only reason people with
pre-existing conditions are none of
private insurance are able to pay this
because they have the Affordable Care
Act
but by the way
[Applause]
you cut the Affordable Care Act millions
could lose free preventive care like
cancer screenings Millers could lose
basic services like maternity care which
ensures would no longer have to cover
up to three million young adults will
lose access to their parents health
insurance which they're on right now if
the Affordable Care Act goes they're the
facts not making any of you as they used
to say is even no longer relevant but
Google it you know you'll see
and nearly 40 million Americans would be
in danger of losing health coverage
completely
that includes millions of low-income
Americans who currently get their health
insurance through Medicaid which
Affordable Care has expanded in 39
States
and it includes millions of middle class
and working-class families who currently
are covered by the ACA Marketplace
even if they did manage to keep their
health insurance
would cost them thousands of dollars
more per year than it does now
that's just a glimpse of the damage of
repealing the Affordable Care Act would
do
you know the Maga republicans in
Congress
are one do they still want to cut
Medicaid
well the former Trump budget director
who's now advising them that as
Republicans in the house
on their fiscal strategy has a plan
to slash over two trillion dollars for
Medicaid
I said well whether it gets patent
that's the plan okay
he wants to end Medicare expansion
under the Affordable Care Act
and then additional deep cuts that could
lead to nearly 70 million people losing
critical services
most of them are seniors people with
disabilities and children
some could lose their health insurance
altogether millions of seniors and
people with disabilities who depend on
Medicaid to help pay for their home care
including home health aids could lose
their ability to remain in their homes
and by the way it saves the government
money if they're home and not in a
nursing home
and
those long waiting lists for Home Care
which has gone down under the last two
years last five years 20 percent
would likely rise again in states with
no waiting lists would likely have them
again
Medicaid also pays for nursing home care
for about two-thirds of all Americans
who live in nursing homes
cut Medicaid and the quality of care in
nursing homes goes down because the help
goes down the salaries go down access
goes down rural hospitals across the
country to depend on Medicare to cover
uncompensated care could close their
doors
already more than 500 rural hospitals
across the country on risk closing you
know what the statistics show
if in fact you have a serious accident
and you're in a rural community
you have a four times greater chance of
dying than if you had the same exact
accident in a community that is more
popular
because you can't get to the hospital
you can't get many places throughout the
Midwest
you have to drive 30 40 miles to get to
a hospital
by that time you're dead not a joke
it's not hyperbole it's a fact
and so folks look
in fact two from 2010 to 2021
over 130 Hospital hospitals did close
entire communities depend on these
hospitals
getting Medicaid
would shut many of them to not getting
medicated and shipment him down studies
show further
that the more the more likely you are to
pass or have serious injury the further
you are from access to a hospital
the time when so many of our kids
are dealing with a painful mental health
challenges
millions could lose access to mental
health care as well
at a time when so many of our loved ones
and neighbors are struggling with opioid
and epidemic on the millions can lose
access to drug treatment facilities
it would be devastating
what about social security Medicare
well are they safe
during the State of the Union as some of
you may have seen
I was
[Applause]
I
I I've been around for a lot of state of
the unions
I never saw one where the president got
to negotiate in the open with everybody
I was pleased to see so many Republicans
stand up remember when Marjorie telegram
was yelling Liar Liar finds a liar
I'm gonna be good
we don't want to cut anything ice so I
when I asked I said okay you don't want
to kind of everybody who says we're not
going to cut Medicare Social Security
when I asked them to join us and reject
the cuts Medicare wasn't it something
they all stood up
all stood up
[Applause]
if they're all on camera
got all their pictures
like I said I believe in conversion
maybe they found as my grandfather's
maybe they found religion
on Social Security Medicare
I sure hope so all can decide but I'll
believe it when I see it for example
Senator Rick Scott of Florida
the guy's been saying for a year
for a long time he wants the sunset
Social Security medic every five years
what that means is every five years it
comes up if you don't vote for back in
existence again
with the same exactly like it was it
goes away or you can reduce it you can
do whatever you want but every five
years has to be voted on
now he says never mind don't need to do
that
although I noticed he didn't say never
mind about Medicaid and the Affordable
Care Act
they're still in the chopping block even
in the senator Scott's plan
look make no mistake
if Mega Republicans
try to take away people's Health Care
by gutting Medicaid and Affordable Care
Act I will stop them
[Applause]
folks
here's the bottom line
the work that we've done
to get more people Affordable Health
Care
and bring down the cost is going to
reduce the deficit significantly
it's making the real difference in
people's lives means more security more
dignity for millions of families
we got more work to do
but we've made a lot of progress
I was in the northern part of your state
about a year ago
doing a town meeting
and a woman stood up and started to talk
about the cost of insulin said I have
two kids and she went on she was very
articulate
and she got a very emotional
she said what do I do I don't can't
afford the insurance but how do I look
at my child
and say I can't help
can't help but like y'all put yourself
in that position
your child has Type 2 diabetes
so we share this
what do you do imagine being in that
circumstance
there's no means by which you could have
changed it now
you've changed it in terms of but we
haven't changed it permanently in terms
of making the same requirements for The
Elder for all people as they do for the
elderly and Medicare
folks families across the country are
starting to breathe this a little easier
you've just got to keep it going
I've long as you said it's never been a
good bet to bet against the American
people
and I can honestly say
[Music]
s i stand here today I've never been
more optimistic about America's future
we just have to remember who we are we
are the United States of America
and there is nothing nothing beyond our
capacity when we work together we can do
anything so God bless you all and may
God protect our troops thank you thank
you thank you
[Music]
thank you